[Music]
and never let go news no you should
always look good Jack had space all know
he did submitted by mill ching-chong AKA
alexei a young woman held on to her
arresting cops hair until it had to be
cut off what the woman held on to the
cops hair yeah is this an America the
cop beat her ass oh damn I think they
have a man but was it a lady cop to be
clear she was a like a peace officer or
some [ __ ] so not like a full-on police
officer the meter maid well peace
officer is a police it's a euphemism
they call them peace officers but
they're so cool I don't know [ __ ] I'm
sorry
the point is she was working at this
University like with the university
police to a little bit different to
regulate underage drinking and so they
pulled over this car because they saw
one of the girls in the car
stick their head out of the sunroof and
do that no matter worried that's a party
thing yeah I've never seen it my
shoulders kind of tight so I'm doing a
little bit of I'm gonna play a video
clip of the arrest
[ __ ] got a wild girls not Wow was that
you know you're going to jail for public
intoxication do you not understand that
so I would stop talking if I were you my
dad is in my back you are going what put
on Facebook live
I'm Debra holy dude to make it safer you
know what's gonna happen when there's
only one they're gonna use even more
force yeah oh my gosh the guy was
cutting her hair cuz the officers don't
cut my hair I don't care cut my hair
well cuz she was grabbing onto the
blocks we didn't let go
oh down not-so-good thing didn't cut her
hand huh you know so the beginning part
that all was not included when Samantha
posted clips on Twitter so she only
included the part about the officer
getting upset about the whole last name
thing so she kind of made it a race
thing where she was like [ __ ] your last
name is [ __ ] she started giving her life
story daddy but he's not my real daddy
and they're like this happened to my
family because the officer wasn't
accepting the fact that she's like she's
by Luna no but that's not what was asked
it was I need your legal name for this
ticket for cuz she's filling up a form
like the officer doesn't care what our
[ __ ] nickname is like I don't care
that people call you Mickey Mouse
she was your real name is this being a
[ __ ]
which one that girl she's being a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] Alonzo
and she said Luna yeah that's like me
saying lemo as my last name and being
like oh I mean Li mo green eyes I go by
Li mo exactly like they don't care what
is all your licence she goes I just told
you people call me Luna it's like no you
didn't answer the question [ __ ] yeah so
then let's win like Twitter to get to
the whole race ID I didn't see anything
racist about it
hoorah of course they're gonna take the
this chick the victim because she she
edited to the black I saw I saw
multicultural police force that was
doing their job white guy with the
Mexican mustache yeah yeah it takes like
some NorCal by the way because girl
fight yeah so the cop get in trouble
then as of right now I mean they're not
really going into much detail like the
police is kind of just being like we're
investigating and not really saying
anything but the the video went viral
because that girl posted she posted
three clips and that's why it was like
spliced together from what I showed you
but then somehow the news sources cuz I
don't know how they got the full video
of the beginning part that should cut
out with the news media outlet they got
that beginning part and so I wanted to
show you guys that cuz you can clearly
tell that she is intoxicated yeah I
never get when people don't cooperate
well she's drinking in public right 2000
she's underage
so she's lucky that she didn't get taken
to the station and just held their like
they weren't gonna take dude just gonna
give her a ticket but yeah it was yeah
she I don't think was she gonna give her
yeah yeah she was gonna give her a
ticket she wasn't gonna arrest her yeah
what the whole thing is she gave herself
more [ __ ] yeah a mouse now there's
like probably an assault to an officer
all the [ __ ] she's five damn I've seen
so many situations where people [ __ ]
get themselves in more trouble yeah she
just wanted to try and get a confusing
last name charge now - no interested for
giving a false identification public
intoxication and resisting arrest and
assaulting a police officer when she
probably could have got it got away with
just a public yeah ticket damn man
that's some [ __ ] she had nice hair
it was like layered or whatever the [ __ ]
thing it was just so obnoxious she goes
what is your legal name on your driver's
like yeah
creeper like no like tell me you're
[ __ ] Brit baby call me smiley yeah
[ __ ] you styler name he had no accent
[ __ ] you guys oh well yeah but she was
trying to pull her brown card but she's
so white yes she could be but she cream
a flex harder than I so let's lose that
I thought she was saying that her last
name is Alonzo Luna but she just told
the officer Luna the first time because
she loved Alonzo ow yeah and then the
officer was giving her [ __ ] about
leaving the Alonzo out yeah she's like
well what is your what is your last name
and she goes well I go by Luna it's like
I didn't ask you what you went by you
never mean I'm asking you that she was
just too drunk to know what was going on
is on your licence I saw this one Luna
means moon yeah so there's one video
where this guy was being asked for his
just driver's license like a normal
ticket stop but he ended up [ __ ]
trying to fight with the cop and he
swung first
oh my ended up where she had an assault
charge in all this [ __ ] and all you got
to do is show the [ __ ] ID so wild man
yeah I don't know why people put
themselves and [ __ ] more problems
than well cuz it is on the only other
side it is so panicky like when a
officer is asking for your information
you're just like what'd I do wrong I
didn't do anything wrong
that's a better approach I just turn
[ __ ] white as the way that people
handle their defensive Ness is different
like me I crumble like this but then
some people are like aggressive like you
I never get aggressive it depends on the
person for Michael as business white
best boss yeah as the cop I'm just like
alright I might just shut the [ __ ] up
whatever you want like I've watched
enough news to know if I'm belligerent
I'm gonna get [ __ ] up yeah cuz
aggression feeds more aggression they
got [ __ ] dogs they got SWAT team you
got helicopters and [ __ ] be smart about
I'm not trying to get my ass bit by a
dog so I'm just gonna to you against the
whole there the whole [ __ ] police
force you can make a stance in court
where it matters you know like document
it cooperate but be smart about it like
if you want to fight racism or whatever
just you know have it recorded do
everything like
where you're right I don't want to get a
beanbag to the face oh god that was so
funny it like I just saw it cuz she's so
annoying she was [ __ ] up and she goes
she goes you know for guys it's funny
too in this article they're saying that
she is now threatening legal action and
told the TV station that she comes with
me meeting with an attorney so like now
she's gonna be suing she still wants to
win
wait for what for rate like for racism
for I don't understand what college was
this do you know
Oh humbled really Humboldt State you
have a great a marine biology [ __ ] out
there or do they yeah on the wall do you
know about that way he's smiling so hard
about it because it's really close to
Monterey he's from North Cal you know
those things he's like they have a
really good marine biology hide his
boner a lot of ocean and nice breezes
over there a lot of white man didn't
know you were so interested in I just
know that I'd well yeah a really good
strain of weed comes from Humboldt
County that's all I know
even now to this day y know this is back
in the day when we'd wasn't legal it was
always at the home [ __ ] yeah my
friend will try to get me to smuggle
with them on the train smuggle everyone
went down there to buy weed and then
come back okay well I know four
different things these are high school
adventures marine biology that's good
aquarium y'all didn't go to [ __ ] the
Monterey Bay Aquarium a boner about it
as a kid it was parents dude the
Monterey Bay grounds one of the biggest
like aquariums out there that's where
they have that big fish with it sunfish
ya know I don't know what that means
Dory was placed there basement oh really
and they have where you can walk under
and it's like Europe I love my parents
always took us there like almost every
summer as a kid
Oh as much as they could because they're
always busy so like they would if they
could they would take it sir at least
want to turn in something so that
charges Neyland Connie yeah to be honest
with you like I love like we should go
there I like that place there's pretty
tighten or take some big-ass sharks
delicious [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
why don't we go to the aquarium and then
after that we'll go moister and and crab
hunting and we could eat what we just
saw you want to go hunting for the way
we can eat the exhibit yeah oh it's
lucky we also have restaurants worth
waiting there cuz I think they always
serve as most or stores are farmed cuz
like the ones in the ocean are nasty
like they're full of act bacteria
nevermind baby
eatin though that mercury huh you're the
pharmacy I shoulda naked afraid they'd
eat them though Panama oysters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]